I'm really, really happy to
be here with you guys today.
It's really exciting.
We have a lot of fantastic
material for you,
all focused on what
we're doing with Chrome
and what we can do to try
to make the web much better,
especially on mobile.
Let's get right to it.
So at I/O earlier
this year, we got
to announce that we have 300
million Chrome on mobile users.
This is fantastic.
It actually represents a 10x
growth over a year earlier.
I think Chrome is actually
relatively new on mobile.
Today, I'm really, really
pleased to announce
that we have 400 million
users of Chrome on mobile.
This is fantastic.
Just in the last
four months we've
seen this kind of
spectacular growth.
I think this is really, really
fantastic, not just because I'm
working on Chrome
and want to see
it be successful, but also what
it means for the mobile web.
I think a lot of times
developers struggle
with trying to reach users
through browsers that are old,
not updating-- and
there's just a lot
of disparity across
the mobile web,
and across the mobile ecosystem
of the types of browsers
that are out there.
So as we get Chrome
out there more,
developers can start to count
on a more consistent web
platform, a more modern
web platform, one that's
auto updating, one that's fast
and it's getting improved.
I think this is
fantastic for what
it means to web
developers trying
to reach users through browsers.
Anyway, so in addition
to just trying
to reach users through browsers,
a lot of web developers
are looking at trying to reach
users through native apps,
obviously, and using
web tech in native apps.
And for a long time, they
struggled with the fact
that the WebViews are old.
And as of Lollipop,
I'm really, really
pleased to announce
that we have support
for auto updating WebView.
This is fantastic.
It means that for
the first time--
[APPLAUSE]
This was a long time
coming to be honest.
I think it was
two I/Os ago where
we were talking about how badly
we wanted to get this done.
Getting it to a place where,
when we update Chrome,
we can also update
WebView, is fantastic.
I think you all
understand this, but just
having a consistent
modern platform
that you can take
advantage of, both
when deploying over the web,
as well as through native apps,
is huge.
I think that a lot
of times people
take for granted that they
have a modern web platform.
That's sort of
the mindset people
are in when they're
focused on desktop,
but it hasn't been
the case on mobile.
So getting to a place where it
is, it's a huge accomplishment.
Now we have been very
busy over the past year.
This is a set of
features that we've
been working on that have
all land in the last year,
and a whole lot
of different work
that's gone in to make Chrome
and the web platform better.
We've been working with
other browser vendors
to bring a lot of
new features-- things
that improve the capabilities
that you get access to,
things that allow
you to take advantage
of mobile, simple
things like Screen
Orientation and
the ability to lock
the orientation of the screen
to portrait or landscape.
These things go a
long way to help
you deliver a great
experience to the web.
But also features that allow
you to have a much better time
creating a good user experience,
a good performant user
experience-- simple things like
the will-change attribute that
lets you inform the
engine that, hey, this
is the kind of animation
I'll be making,
allows the engine to make a
lot of optimizations for you.
But that's not it.
There's a lot of
other things here.
Features like Web Animations
that give developers a lot more
control over the
animation system,
rather than forcing you to
cobble together CSS strings
to generate the kind
of animations you want.
We've also put a lot
of work over many years
to build up a set of features
that powers web components--
things like Custom Elements,
HTML Imports, and Shadow DOM.
And all these things are
now shipping natively
in Chrome, which is just
fantastic because it means
as you're using
toolkits like Polymer,
or just other toolkits that
leverage web components,
you're getting a
native implementation
of those features.
It's too many things
to mention here.
I'll just say, in
addition to features,
we've been very
focused on performance.
Optimizing the engine,
improving performance
reducing CPU load,
et cetera-- these
are things that are just
very important for developers
who are trying to create
a great experience.
One feature I really
want to call attention to
is something that we actually
removed from the platform
a little under year ago.
It used to be that when the
user would tap on the browser,
there would be a 300 millisecond
delay, while the browser was
trying to figure out-- did the
user mean to click on a link,
or are they trying to
zoom, et cetera-- removing
this allowed
developers to have much
more control over
animations to be
able to provide much
smoother experiences.
[APPLAUSE]
Yes, this one deserves
a round of applause.
It was actually a heroic
effort to get there,
but it's fantastic that we
can now take for granted
that you don't have it.
So with all this great
work that's happening,
it seems like the
mobile web is awesome.
Right?
Well, well, you
commonly hear this meme.
The stories are rolling
out all the time about,
native apps killing
the mobile web,
the demise of the
mobile web seems
imminent-- shouldn't we all
just be writing native apps?
Well I think the
story is actually
a bit more nuanced than
that-- a bit more interesting,
if you dig down.
And we think there's actually a
lot of value to the mobile web,
if you start to
explore it further.
There were some studies
earlier in the year by Flurry
that showed that
time spent on mobile
is actually heavily biased
towards native apps,
and very little
time spent on sites.
But you have to sort of
explore this a little bit
further to see what's
really going on.
In fact, the time
spent in native apps
is dominated by activities
like gaming, entertainment,
and social.
And time spent with
other activities-- well,
it's much smaller.
So that's only part
of the picture.
And indeed, if you look
further at the time spent
on the mobile, actually that
vast majority of time that
was spent in native
apps, it's really
dominated by just
a few native apps.
And as a developer
trying to reach users,
writing a native app doesn't
mean that suddenly you're
getting a lot more attention.
In fact I'd argue
that, in many ways,
it's easier to get
attention if you're
deploying through the web.
In fact, if you're
specifically going
after commercial activity,
and you talk to users,
and you say, how do they use
their mobile devices when
they're interested in shopping,
or e-commerce type activities--
users resoundingly talk
about how they use the web.
And this kind of makes sense.
You think about it--
how many store apps
do you actually install?
Well you might have installed,
say, the Amazon app,
but actually when
you're going shopping,
you want to do a lot
of comparison shopping.
You're going to do
searches, and so on, and be
looking for best prices,
or doing comparison
shopping across different sites.
And actually, the web
is really good at this.
And indeed it's actually
really good at helping
users find interesting things.
And as a developer
trying to reach users
and-- there's just
a lot of power here.
So what makes the web
ideal for success?
There's a lot of
things, and I want
to get into that a
little bit further.
I think one of the
biggest things--
this is very obvious, really.
It's just that when you
put things on the web,
there's a lot of
tools that help you
make your content, your
apps, discoverable.
There's a lot of great
tools-- obviously, Search.
You work at Google.
Search engine is a
very powerful tool
that can drive
traffic to websites.
Ads can drive
traffic to websites,
social media can drive
traffic to websites.
A lot of this is powered by
URLs, and the indexability
of content, and all
of the great tools
that are available
for SEO, and so on.
These things enable users
to easily find things.
They can also
easily share things.
And it's not just your
application or the entry point
to your website, but it's deep
linking into your websites.
Particular pieces of
content or particular states
of applications-- developers
have an easy time presenting
these things as URLs, and
users have an easy time
sharing them and
discovering them.
This is actually a very powerful
feature of the web platform.
It's a fantastic way to
deploy stuff, and get it
in front of users.
When the web
platform, in addition
to having that discoverability
and that reach,
it's actually a very,
very comforting to a user
if they're given a URL.
Clicking on a URL feels
like a very safe action.
It's not scary to someone.
Whereas installing a native
app, it's a bit scary.
It can be.
You're not sure-- what
are you giving up?
You're accepting a
battery of permissions,
and so you can
imagine a lot of users
feel a little bit
unsure about that.
But with the URL to a site,
it's actually very safe.
It feels safe.
There's a history of
browsers doing a good job
protecting users.
But all of this really
leads up to the big benefit
of the web, which I think
is that it's a fantastically
low friction way for users
to connect with developers,
for developers to get
user experiences in front
of customers.
The web is this
ephemeral platform.
There's no install prompts.
It's very easy for folks to
find things through search,
through ads, through tweets,
and social media and such,
and end up right
there on a site,
on a page, where they
could buy something,
or where they can
complete some transaction,
or they can do something that
they're interested in doing.
So there's a lot of upside
if we can get to a place
where you can create great
experiences on the web
because there's all this
fantastic environment that
can maximize what you
can get out of it.
So that's all very exciting.
Like I said, there's
a lot more that we
need to do because in this
day and age people are
very excited about native apps.
The web itself has
been this platform
that hasn't worked
great on mobile.
Everybody's pretty
aware of these problems.
There's a variety of problems,
from performance problems,
to hard to take advantage
of mobile devices and create
great experiences, to frustrated
with buggy browsers and such.
So there's a lot
of work that has
to be done to make the
environment better,
but we're getting there, and
there's a lot that were doing.
So I want to talk about
some of those things.
But first off, this
summit's mostly about Chrome
and what the Chrome
team 's doing.
Google Search, just
yesterday, rolled out
a really exciting
feature, which is
they are starting
to badge websites,
in search results, that
are mobile friendly.
This is all something that
you can explore further
through Webmaster Tools.
You can see the
validation tool that
helps you understand if your
site is mobile-friendly, and so
on.
But this is all about
helping users understand
that if they're going to
follow a search result,
they're going to end up on
a site that actually works
or should work on their
mobile device, that's
not going to flash.
It's not going to be
a desktop, or InSight.
It's not going to have
very small text, et cetera.
I think this is a very useful
tool for both developers
and users.
And so I'm really
excited about it.
On Chrome's side,
our goal is really
about helping developers
be more productive.
And to do that, we have a long
history of, for example, making
better developer tools.
The DevTools has been
a fantastic project.
You're going to get
to hear a lot more
about that later today.
We have done a lot
of work to help
you use DevTools on desktop
to explore how your site works
on mobile devices,
which is very useful.
And a lot of work's gone
into helping you understand
animation performance,
and so on.
You can learn a lot more
about that later today.
We've also been
doing a lot of work
on toolkits, and things
like web fundamentals
to help folks get started,
and orient themselves,
and understand how to
optimize for mobile.
I'm very excited about Polymer
as a great reference toolkit
for how to build
fantastic websites that
run well on mobile.
You'll hear more about
Polymer if you don't already
know about it, but
it's our expression
of what we think a
great framework can be.
In addition to
productivity, we're
working a lot to make
the engines faster,
and to help developers create
more performant websites.
We know that this is the thing
that folks struggle with.
The engines haven't always
been tuned for mobile.
They weren't designed
for mobile originally.
And so we've spent a
lot of time just working
on core rendering performance.
A lot of this is about
optimizing existing code pass,
but moving workloads to GPUs.
So we're rolling out
GPU rasterization, which
is really fantastic--
allows for web developers
to take full advantage
of the more capable GPUs
that you find on mobile devices,
and relieve the CPUs of all
the burden, and in doing so,
reduce power consumption,
and so on.
So there's a lot that
can be done there.
Ryan's going to talk
more about performance.
A lot of work going
into V8, et cetera.
But in addition to just
optimizing the engine,
we also want to do feature
work that allows developers
to have a lot more control over
the platform, and, in doing so,
be able to have more
control over where
the expensive things
happen, and when they happen
and-- for example, when it comes
to network resource loading,
developers often
struggle with the fact
that the browser sort of feels
like it's out of your control.
If there's a network
error, suddenly the user
sees a browser error page.
It's not a great experience.
With a service
worker API that we're
going to talk a lot more
about, among other things,
you actually do get the control
over the network fetching,
and network resource
loading and caching.
It allows for developers to
cope better with poor network
conditions, and so
on, but also allows
them to guarantee that when
your application starts up,
it actually loads quickly
and reliably fast,
assuming you've had a chance
to populate your caches,
which is great.
I'm very excited about
that because it really
is one of these things
that often developers
suffer when they're thinking
about deploying over the web
and over potentially
poor network connections
that people often have
to deal with with mobile.
So anyways, in addition
to all of that,
we're trying to help
developers provide
a much more engaging
experience on mobile.
And here's where we're doing
some really exciting things,
exploring how to,
for example, allow
you to integrate the web
experience deeper into Android
and allow it to feel like a more
first class part of the system.
And a while back, we rolled out
support for Add To Home Screen.
But we're working
on exploring how
to elevate Add To Home Screen
so that users discover it
more readily, under
the right conditions.
I think this is a
very important thing.
I think a lot of developers are
interested in the re engagement
that happens when you have
a home screen placement.
And this is
something that's been
difficult to achieve on the
web, unless users really
knew what they were doing
and went looking for it.
In Lollipop, we
rolled out support
for exploding and
moving the tabs
of the browser out
into the Recents view,
so that web content
rendered through Chrome
would actually appear as a
peer to native applications.
This is huge because it
allows a web developer to feel
like their experience is not
trapped within a browser,
but rather it's a first
class experience on Android.
And though these screenshots
don't really show it,
the one on the right
emphasizes that you actually
get a lot more control
over the theming.
And in addition to
theming, you actually
get a lot more control
over the iconography.
One of our goals with
this whole user experience
here was to try to put
Chrome in the background,
and let the content
take the stage.
It's really important
that-- we feel that users,
they think deeply about
interacting with sites--
not Chrome.
It's important for
them to understand
that they're working with
food.com-- not Chrome.
And so we've done a lot with
the system UI, and Chrome's UI,
to try to help put
the content first,
help put the web
applications first.
And so a lot of this
work that you see here
is an effort towards that.
In addition, there's also
a lot of work going on
with capabilities.
And I already mentioned
service worker,
and how it can help
solve for offline,
and solve for poor
network connections.
That's just a
fundamental thing that's
been missing from the platform.
We've had app cache, but it's
so limited and hard to use.
Service worker is
much easier to use.
On the back of
service worker, we
can do a lot of
fantastic things though.
We can solve finally for
background processing.
We can enable developers to
update their caches of content
and code in the background, so
that when the user interacts
with the site again,
they're getting not just
cached content, but they're
getting fresh cached content.
And you as a developer can
have control over that.
This is something that's
under development.
It's not done yet, but we're
very excited about enabling
background processing on mobile
for web content delivered
through the browser.
Push notifications is
something that we can also
start to build on top
of the ServiceWorker.
And it's something that
we're close to launching.
And it's very exciting to
enable developers to have access
to push notifications
because it allows for, again,
another form of re engagement.
One of the things we're doing
is being very thoughtful
though about how we keep users
in control of the experience.
I think that's-- as
I mentioned earlier,
around safety and so on,
users want to feel like
they're in control
of the experience.
We also want to figure out
how to allow developers
have a lot more power in
terms of the experience they
can present.
And as a browser,
as a user agent,
we're actually in a
very good position
to do something
innovative there.
So today's all about you
all connecting with us.
We have a bunch of
Chrome developers
here to talk about the
work they're doing.
As you saw, this talk was
very focused on mobile web,
and a lot of the sessions
are all jam-packed,
focused on mobile web.
There's so much to talk
about and not enough time.
There's plenty of
other material outside
of this context
and people here who
can help answer those questions.
We will have booths, and
sessions, and panels tomorrow.
And throughout the day, there's
lots of opportunities for you
to connect with developers--
really want to hear from you,
hear what you care about.
Because ultimately we want to
help make you all successful.
So with that, I'm really
excited to see and learn
what you guys can create
on top of the platform
that we're building.
So thank you so much
for joining us today.
It's an exciting day.
I think there's so much
to learn and explore.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]